you bienvenue dans le second épisode du
coup de fil c'est toi moi parce cantona
la philosophie on va goûter à la
philosophie politique avec machiavel
philosophie politique
mike leinbach carrick man et on va
parler de son oeuvre phare le prince de
machiavel vous dit quelque chose c'est
sûrement parce que ce mec a donné son
nom à l'un des adjectifs les plus dark
de la langue française et on se dit que
si ce mec a donné son nom à ça si tu
doit forcément être timbré avec une
grosse gueule de pervers en plein dans
le mille oui j'aime manger les petits
enfants sans défense avec de la sauce
harissa en mode salades tomates oignons
hormis le fait qu'il ressemble grave un
mec de planète des singes niccolo
machiavelli alias machiavel et non 1469
en italie à florence
alors l'italie à cette période là c'est
complètement divisé morcelé voilà une
carte
ok cool et en plus lui pour se
compliquer la tâche était dans la vie
politique
quand les médicis sont arrivés à
florence ils ont salement virer tout
genre y ont torturés exilés et c'est en
exil qu'il écrit le prince oui enfin
milliers ici et ce midi c'est tout mais
dix huit
enfin c'était le peuple avec les cadrans
solaires ne nous étions pas vraiment
précis dans notre univers temporel dans
ce livre il explique quelles sont les
différents types d'étape
comment les conquérir et enfin il donne
une série de conseils au prince pour
garder le contrôle sur son état
d'ailleurs en 1928 le dictateur italien
mussolini décrit ce livre comme le guide
suprême de l'homme d'état en gros pour
lui c'est le manuel du dictateur et à un
trouver un signe distinctif petite
moustache du führer ou call maoïstes
là je suis crédible 30 coups de fouet
pour toi je suis ton droit respecte moi
étape 2 pour montrer que vous n'êtes pas
un rigolo tué un membre de votre famille
maman tu peux venir ça me plaît
et dans son livre et des trucs dingues
genre il est plus sûr d'être craint que
d'être aimé en fait s'il dit ça c'est
parce que la peur est un sentiment
beaucoup plus contrôlable lui que
l'amour l'amour est un peu volatil et
peut se retourner contre toi d'ailleurs
il dit bien que tu dois être craints et
paille et pour ne pas se faire haïr des
hommes tu ne vois pas toucher à leurs
femmes et leurs biens ce qui je pense
pour machiavel devait être
rigoureusement identique
l'idée aussi par exemple que le principe
à savoir simuler et dissimuler mon
appartement par omission la france c'est
simule gelant des fonds sprott
non non c'est non non c'est pas du tout
ça en gros si dit qu'il doit savoir
simuler et dissimulé c'est qu'il doit
faire la distinction entre l'être et le
paraître
je dois pas faire n'importe quoi devant
tout le monde et je te faire attention à
l'image que je dégage en tant que
principe il est aussi que les hommes
doivent être caressé ou détruit des
hommes doivent être caressé est ok ok ok
avec isla l'islam lui était dans la
caverne avec les autres en fait et
platon et compagnie soirée tous à poils
longs se caressent nicolas machiavel et
ses bontés je peux pas te b les hommes
doivent être caressé ou détruits
qu'est-ce que machiavel veux dire par là
imaginons tu veut punir quelqu'un si tu
te punit un peu il va vouloir se venger
à dit tu vois donc soit tu ne punit pas
soit si tu es puni tu t'arranges pour
qu'ils puissent jamais se venger genre
tu te défonces sa mère tu vois un peu
comme le caïd en voir deux villes dans
cette ville dominée par la peur le guide
ne se contente pas de vous tuer
tu toute votre famille relata patrons
touchés le terrible et machiavel
justifie tout ça en disant que les
hommes sont mauvais de nature ils sont
ingrats inconstant simulateur et des
simulateurs fuyards devant les périls
avides de gain la positive attitude
franchement c'est un bâtard machiavel
c'est chaud c'est ce qu'on pourrait
croire mais pas du tout machiavel ne dit
pas de faire du mal ou faire du bien il
est de faire ce qui doit être fait pour
le bien du royaume
que ce soit bien ou mal d'où la phrase
que vous connaissez sûrement la fin
justifie les moyens
et quand on dit la fin c'est l'objectif
ok c'est pas la fin est faille aime bien
manger parce que la fin ne justifie pas
les moyens
ouais mais c'est peut-être en ben en
fait ce qu'explique machiavel c'est que
le prince ne peut pas faire des trucs
qui sont que dans la morale parce que la
morale limite grave des actions par
exemple aider les autres est gentil se
faire respecter
tu es ou même pire prendre le métro sans
ticket bas si je prends toutes ces
actions là il n'y a que les trois
premières qui sont dans la morale du
coup c'est le prince doit se limiter à
la morale il peut pas faire tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour le bien du royaume
c'est ce qu'explique ra's al ghul dans
batman begins à batman
lorsque pas feint de refusent de tuer un
homme donc pour cette cause supérieure
qui est le bien la nation le prince à
devoir faire une croix sur sa mort a
alors il ya différentes réactions
philosophe et à nietzsche qui trouvent
ça trop cool ou ceux qui trouvent ça
pourrit et moi j'aime bien la réaction
de francis bacon qui dit que les peuples
devraient utiliser le livre du prince
pour mieux anticiper et comprendre les
gens qui les dirigent j'espère que le
prince de machiavel est maintenant plus
clair pour vous en ce que je voulais
grave vous remercier pour vos
commentaires et vos suffrages
la guerre était ça fait plaisir si cette
vidéo vous a plu bah vous savez ce qu'il
vous reste à faire passer confie la main